[Music]
we've got esmerelda on the line in
stockton california and we'll see what
her question is esmerelda welcome to the
ramsay show
hi guys thank you for taking my call
sure speak directly into your phone it
sounds a little noisy
so i just had a quick question um
i am about to switch because my careers
but jobs
um
i'm currently work as a correctional
nurse and i make about 120 000 a year
and i'm going to go be a school nurse to
have my kids full schedule and my salary
is going to drop down to about
80 000 a year
and my husband makes about 120 as well
and we just sold our car so we just got
rid of 33 000
and we have about 35 000 in credit card
debt and about 180 in our mortgage
so i just wanted to know i'm just having
a hard time with the whole salary
reduction and how much is enough for a
family
that's a great question and you guys are
in california and so i know this looks
different for people in high cost of
living areas but you don't get a pass on
the math and the truth is
it really doesn't matter i mean there's
people who make forty thousand dollars
who live very comfortably there's people
who live in million dollar houses who
feel like they don't have enough and so
what's going to make you feel like you
have enough is when you have margin and
right now you've got a pile of debt here
in 35 000 of credit card debt that's
making you feel like you don't have
enough and so can you live on 200 000
income which is what you'll go to in
california comfortably yeah you can but
not when you have a pile of debt
breathing down your net estimator what's
the 35 000 i know it's credit card debt
but like what what are you guys charging
on oh
it was just we did um furniture and just
like odds and ends that have piled up
over the years yeah so over the years
you've been paying on this debt for a
long time
probably about two years just kind of
the last year and a half we've just kind
of been living life and
um
yeah buying stuff going on vacation and
now that i'm able to i finished my bsn
so i was able to apply for a school
nurse position and now that i'm actually
gonna take it i'm like whoa well i know
i'm going to take a pick up but now i'm
like oh is this the right move right now
brad
yeah well i mean here's the deal you're
still going to be making around 200 if
you're making 80 he's making 120
you guys are still making an incredible
income
and so
y'all's issue is gonna have to be hey
i'm gonna have to set some boundaries
and actually get serious about this
because you guys have kind of just been
floating around having fun going on
vacation buying stuff and just not
really thinking because you've had the
money to cover your mistakes and
suddenly when you don't have the money
to cover your mistakes anymore and
you're down forty thousand dollars a
year
yeah it's gonna you're gonna feel
exactly what you're calling right you're
feeling that intensity and and as well
that's the intensity that you're going
to have to clean this up i mean people
they do it all the time and and if i
were you guys i mean your life is gonna
look
drastically different for the next nine
months of your life like i would buckle
down and do nothing i would i would sell
some stuff you guys bought on those
credit cards that you're not using
anymore i would not go out to eat i
would not go on vacation i would do
nothing and i would get rid of this
because if you can take this intensity
and actually get serious about it this
35 thousand dollars will go away you
guys have the income to be able to do it
you're going to be able
to really knock this out even if you go
and take the nursing job which i'm not
mad if you do that i think that if
that's what you're wanting to do that's
great because you guys still are going
to have a great income to pay this off
but you got to get serious about it and
you guys have not been serious about
this and man when you pay this off like
george said it's going to put you in a
different spot it is going to it is
going to bring the freedom that you're
wanting right now to be able to switch
jobs and not feel distressed
okay yeah we sold our cards um on monday
which that took off 33 000 and we have
two other cars that are paid for so
we're good with that and my husband's
like i'm so proud of you you actually
gave up a nice luxury car to drive your
paid off car i was like well i want to
do this i want to be able to be home and
spend more time with the kids and you
know my salary eventually will go up to
a hundred thousand in about three years
each year i'll get a pay raise and of
course he will as well
so i guess it's just a drop down right
now that i'm like oh we're gonna get to
get adjusted a little bit and well
here's the thing esmeralda you called
asking how much money do you need to
live comfortably and right now i don't
want you to be comfortable i want you to
be uncomfortable for a short season
so that you can live your best life
later on completely debt-free because
clearly this comfortable living doing
whatever you guys wanted to do it's not
a great life because you're sitting here
with a little bit of anxiety about is
money enough and what about these bills
that we're paying and maybe some buyers
remorse some regret some shame and i
don't want any of that in your life and
you guys have a fantastic income like
rachel said buckle down get rid of this
thing in six months
and uh clean up get an emergency fund in
place do you guys have any savings right
now
we do we have about um like 20 000 or so
okay well if you're following the baby
steps throw it at the debt you've got 1
000 starter and 19 is going to get
thrown on that 35 of credit card debt
and all of a sudden you're gonna go oh
my gosh we can see the light at the end
of the tunnel i i would write a big
check tonight esmeralda i really would
because i i y'all need a shock you need
like george said you kind of just been
floating around like you you need
something kind of shocked the system and
man when you do that and you soccer and
you said okay we're gonna just throw
this get rid of all this other debt pay
down the credit card
it's gonna make you get into gear to pay
off the rest because you're gonna want
that emergency fund back because you
want to get comfortable again which i
don't blame you but you need a little
you need a little shock to the system
yeah i'm here for it you guys got it you
guys got it esmerell you could do this
i'm not worried about it but you're
gonna have to get some self-discipline
in place and get uncomfortable so that
you can be comfortable later on that's
true financial peace